>> It's a pleasure to
have Dawn with us.
Dawn Woodard leads data
science for Uber maps which is
the mapping platform used in
Uber's writer application,
driver app and decision
systems including the
pricing and dispatch.
The teams technologies
that she's overseeing
include roadmap and points
of interests definitions,
map search, route optimization,
travel-time prediction.
Which we know we can confirm,
we do you understand
deeply and do
a good job with and navigation.
So Dawn did her
undergraduate work at
Stanford in Math and CS
and then went off to Duke.
Where she did a PhD in
statistics and then she became
a faculty member in OR and if
mission engineering
at Cornell where
she worked on a
number of projects
including ambulance
decision support systems,
optimization of I guess
placement for ambulances
including a bit I'd say
a variety of interesting projects
even in medical statistics.
Performance assessment
for radiologists
was looking over your
papers that's not
even though you
were in that field
doing work in the field earlier.
After she'd get a tenure
at Cornell and she came to
MSR for her sabbatical that's
where I got to know her.
So we actually we were
delighted to provide Dawn and
her student the time
with family and a home
up in Seattle and I think
that worked out really well,
we had a lot of fun
working on with Paul
[inaudible] and Johnson on doing
predictions with
traffic predictions
or forecasting with Bing
data and at the time Bing
was quite generous with datasets
and with helping us with
that research project.
It's kind of extended clear flow
the clear flow effort which
is now shipping worldwide.
And we were surprised
to find that the
she instead of going back
to Cornell straight
ahead I use to it
went back for
a little bit to Cornell.
>> I know.
>> Never did?
>> Was at Stanford
afterwards and then.
>> Right to Uber okay.
I know at one point
in time she tried
to recruit me to come to Uber.
It was very informal though and
but we stayed in touch and
it's great to have you
back to tell us today about
matching and dynamic pricing
for ride-hailing, so Dawn.
>> Thank you so much Eric.
It's great to be back at MSR,
had an incredible experience
the last time,
I was here this right despite
the little disruption I
think we really landed with
an amazing project here at MSR
in Redmond working together
with Bing Maps team.
So I'll talk a bit about
maps today but I'll also,
I'll focus on the
pricing and matching techniques
that you might be
familiar with as
user of ride-hailing platforms.
I'm going to start with
a story about surge pricing.
So this is an example
of a situation where surge
pricing worked well.
This is the close of
an Ariana Grande concert
in 2015 in Madison Square Garden.
The period in yellow is
the time period in which
surge pricing kicked in
because demand was very high
at the end of the event.
So on the X-axis, we're looking
at time and on the left,
you can see the number of
ride requests and you can see
that at the end of the game
the number of ride
request does go up,
surge pricing kicks in.
As we look in the middle plot,
we see that the time to pick up,
the time between when
the rider requests and
one there picked
up by the driver,
does increase during
this time period
but it only goes from
about two minutes to
about 3.5 minutes.
So still very reasonable.
On the right-hand side,
what you're seeing
is a time series of
the request completion rate
meaning out of riders
who've requested
what proportion had a vehicle
dispatched to them and in fact
that number is so
close to one you
can't really see the
purple, the purple curve.
Contrast with an example
where we had a surge
outage and this occurred
in 2015 New Year's Eve
in New York City.
The period of the outage
is shown in red.
On the left, we're looking
at the number of requests,
the number of requests
skyrockets during
this during this time period.
In the middle, we're
looking again at
those pickup times and you
can see that the pickup time
skyrocket from about two
minutes to about eight minutes,
so very long pickup
times affecting the riders
and the drivers.
And when you look on
the right-hand side,
this is the worst piece
of the picture.
>> Technically, what
an outage means,
this is a communication failure?
>> Sorry an outage means that
the prices did not rise
during this time period.
>> Because of?
>> Because because our
systems went down basically.
So you can see that out
of rider requests during
the outage fewer
than 25 percent of
those riders were actually
dispatched the car.
So this was a this is
a failure of our system.
This is an example of
my first argument which will
be that the matching techniques,
matching how we match riders with
drivers and riders with
each other and carpools.
And techniques for dynamic
pricing keep the amount of
wasted time for riders
and drivers very low in
these ride-hailing systems and
ensure reliability
of the service.
I'll also show that
if that the introduction
of some novel
matching approaches could reduce
the variability that's
introduced by dynamic pricing,
so the downside of
dynamic pricing of
course is that it leads
to this variability in
prices over time and
a bit of unpredictability
and prices both for
riders and for drivers.
So first, I'll talk
about a bit of context,
we'll walk through matching
and dynamic pricing,
I'll dive deep and
dynamic pricing
and I'll talk about
how we estimate
the inputs to pricing
and matching
algorithms or at least
illustrate how that can be done.
Then I'll argue that these
novel matching algorithms can
could potentially reduce
price variability
to the benefit of
both riders and drivers.
But first, a little bit about
my time at Uber I joined
Uber about three years ago.
I was leading the team
called Marketplace
which create the pricing
and matching systems
for Uber and also
all of the inputs to
those algorithms like
the predictions of supply
and demand as well as
travel time in
the road network which is
part of our our mapping service.
Now, I focus on the maps piece
of the picture,
I lead data science
for Uber maps.
Maps does a bunch
of different things
that Eric mentioned and here's
an illustration of
predicted travel speeds
in the Bay Area,
San Francisco Bay Area
road network,
I'll talk a bit about
this plot later.
So most critically for
pricing and matching techniques,
the mapping service
does prediction
of traffic and travel-time
conditions in
real-time and recommends routes
and predicts travel times
from point A to point B.
So if we are
dispatching a vehicle,
we need to know how
long it would take
that driver to get to that rider,
so it's a critical input
to the matching systems that
we'll talk about today.
So I don't think I have to
convince this audience that
ride-hailing has been growing
at a remarkable rate.
So on the right-hand side,
we're looking at
the volume of Uber trips
by year since 2010.
This is through improved
convenience and efficiency of
the service and I'll argue
that techniques for matching
riders with drivers and
for calibrating demand
with supply through
dynamic pricing are
important in creating
this growth.
I'll argue specifically
that these techniques
reduce the amount of wasted time
for riders and drivers
on the platform,
which creates a seamless service
and ensures that
riders and drivers
really engage at high volumes
with the platform.
So if we look on
the left-hand side on
the driver side of
the picture and look at
the percentage of time that
drivers spend with
a passenger in the vehicle,
that's the time period
in which they're being
paid per mile, per minute.
And compare taxi service
to UberX in three
different cities,
we see considerably
higher utilizations
for Uber than for
the taxi services in two
out of the three cities.
New York City is
a slightly different case
because of the density
of both taxi and
Uber in the city,
the utilizations are very
similar in New York City.
If we look at the rider
side of the picture. Yes?
>> You have any reason
why the utilization is
lower in New York compared
to San Francisco?
>> Lower on UberX, this is
2015 data I imagine
it's the picture's changed
a little bit since then.
>> But.
>> I'm not 100 percent certain.
>> Well, New York is flooded
with cabs in some ways so
it's just always seems like
it's a bright love of
yellow the whole city.
I'm guessing that the density of
cabs higher in New York City,
so that might be.
>> It might be there
might be some,
I'm not- I don't know the answer
to that question. It's
a great question.
>> If you just stick
your arm out of cabs,
no matter where
you are most times
of day except for one in raining.
>> Yeah.
>> So that's might
put a dent in Uber.
Uber insanity. That's
me just guessing.
>> Like, when the drivers
are not of the two,
what percentage of the time they
are moving and what percentage
they are just
sitting and waiting?
>> That's a great
question. I don't have
data for you in the presentation.
We will talk about
the implications
of there's these three states
the driver cycle through,
and some of the implications
for the mathematical models,
but I don't have empirical data
for you on that.
On the righter side
of the picture,
in terms of comparing
the amount of
wasted time for riders,
the wasted time for a rider
is the time that
they have to wait
between when they request a ride
and when they're picked up.
So, this is a
simulation comparison
between ride-hailing services
and street-hailing services,
in other words, taxi
style services.
So, the blue curve is
the ride-hailing services and
the green dotted curve is
the street-hailing services,
and in the simulated grid,
the author saw
lower pick-up times for
riders on the
ride-hailing services
than on the
street-hailing services.
So, you can see less wasted time
both for riders and for drivers.
>> On the streets, you just put
your hand out, and
the taxi comes.
>> But, you have to wait
for the taxi to come.
So, there are taxis circulating,
and when this other
rider wants a ride.
>> [inaudible] you see it. So, if
it is two meters away from me,
the waiting time is like zero?
>> Into the time between
when the rider wants
the ride and there's
a driver passing by for
which they can hail.
That's the way the
simulation is done.
Great. So, the matching
in the context of
ride hailing means how do we
match riders with drivers,
in the case of UberX for example,
and how do we match riders
together with each other and
with a driver in these real-time
carpools for uberPOOL.
The dynamic pricing piece
of the puzzle, on the left,
I'm showing the upfront price
that's shown in the Uber app,
and as part of calculating
this upfront price,
there's this surge multiple.
So, you can think about
a slightly simplified scenario,
not quite this
simple in practice,
but think about paying
a base time and distance
per mile and per minute,
and then when demand is
much higher than supply,
the surge multiple goes above
one meaning that riders are
paying that multiple of
the normal time
and distance fare,
and drivers are being paid
that multiple of the normal time
and distance fare.
I guess it's not quite
that simple but you
can think about a 2x
surge multiple as being
roughly doubling the price
for riders and
the payment for drivers.
So, we're going to talk
today about how a
surge price might be
calculated and so we're
showing a heat map of
the surge multiple
on the right-hand side
where darker purple
means a higher surge multiple.
So, the simplest matching
algorithm that you could
think of would be to,
as soon as a rider
requests a ride to simply
dispatch the car that can get
to that rider the fastest.
That's called the first
dispatch protocol and that's
the dispatch protocol that was
used in the simulation
that I showed you before.
So, even this very simple type of
dispatch protocol does lead
to these high efficiencies.
That being said, there's
a variety of ways
to decrease that
pickup time even more,
and I'll show you
an example of one.
But, before I do that,
I do just want to point
out the fact that the key input
for dispatch decisions is
this prediction of travel time
and the road network,
how long will this
pickup take for example.
>> Question?
>> Yes.
>> What do you
compare when you say
you take the closest
one, for example.
This already lowers
as compared to what?
>> This comparison is done,
there's a simulation where we're
comparing a call system,
in other words,
a ride-hailing style system
with a street-hailing service,
like a taxi service.
>> How did you get
that information from taxi?
>> This is a simulation again.
There's a grid, and on
the x-axis is congestion level,
meaning how many riders
and drivers did we
simulate in the grid,
what's the density of
riders and drivers.
This is not based on actual data.
So, I'll show you a mechanism
that can further reduce
these pickup times,
it's called Trip Upgrade,
and it's a simple idea.
So, if a rider is matched
with a driver and
then another driver becomes
available and another
rider requests a ride,
it may be advantageous
to all parties if we
swap the match instead of
matching rider B with driver B.
So, simple concept,
this match swapping,
but again, it has to make
everybody's pickup time lower.
So, here's an illustration,
so we'll start from
the beginning.
So, there's rider A and
driver A, they're
matched together,
they have a six-minute ETA,
and then a second driver
and a second rider appear,
and the match is swapped.
So, simple mechanism,
but you can see that it
decreases the pickup time
for all the parties.
There's a variety of
different mechanisms like this,
I'm not going to get into
detail on any others because I
want to dive deep in
the dynamic pricing context.
We will come back to
matching and tie it
into dynamic pricing
in the last section.
So, let's think
about how one might
calculate a surge multiple.
So, somehow this should be
based on local supply and
demand conditions.
We're somehow trying to
calibrate demand with supply.
So, on the left hand side, I'm
showing a key measure of demand,
which is how many riders are
opening the app and checking
the price as a function
of geolocation.
On the bottom left, I'm showing
the number of open vehicles,
vehicles that are
available to dispatch.
Somehow, we need to combine
these together with
some other inputs to
calculate a surge multiple.
Was there a question in the back?
>> Is the surge multiple
expected not only to
reduce the demand but
also increase the supply?
Is it predictable so
that drivers will start
driving when there's a surge?
>> That's a great question.
What tends to happen
is that drivers
know the time periods
and locations in
which there tends to be
high surge and you do see
that they they come
out and drive more in,
at bar close for example,
or in morning or
evening rush hour,
these peak times
and locations. Yes.
>> It's an effect that
you'd have to see over
time as people learn the
surge multiple right?
>> That's correct.
There's more debate
about whether they
respond to the surge in
a very short-term way,
like when they see the surge,
they can see the surge heatmap.
But, there is a lot of evidence
that they do come out and
drive more at the times and
locations where there
tends to be surge.
How might we determine
this surge multiple?
So, I'm going to go back to
very simple concepts
from your Econ101 class.
We're going to build on these,
this kind of model doesn't
work straight out of the box,
so you could imagine there's
a demand curve as a
function of price,
there's a supply curve
as a function of price,
and there's a market
equilibrium price
where those two intersect here,
I'm just neglecting the fact that
the platform takes
a commission for simplicity,
but it doesn't fundamentally
change the spectrum.
So, we'll use the concept of
producer surplus and
consumer surplus;
the producer in our case being
the driver and the consumer
being the rider,
and so this area in blue
is a measure of how much value
is created for the driver,
the difference between
the amount that the
driver's paid and basically,
their costs including
opportunity costs.
On the red area is a measure of
how much rider value is
created on the platform,
in other words, the difference
between the value that
the rider gains from
the ride and the amount
that they're paying.
So, if we add up the red area
and the blue area,
that's called the welfare,
and that's a measure of
how much value was created
for riders and drivers.
So, it's not this simple in
the context of ride hailing,
but we need these concepts,
and notice that this market
equilibrium price
is the price that
maximizes the welfare.
So, in our context,
there's three states that
drivers cycle through,
Michael referred to this earlier.
There's the open state
when they're
available to be dispatched,
there's the enroute state
where they're on
their way to pick up a rider,
and there's the on-trip state.
So, the riders are
sensitive not just
to price but also to pickup
time because that's
the wasted time for them.
The drivers on the other hand
are sensitive to
both open and enroute time
because they're not being
paid during that time period;
they're paid during this
on-trip time period.
>> I don't think
it will give them [inaudible]
open time into
two different types of time,
moving and not moving,
like rebalancing and
not rebalancing.
>> Rebalancing and
>> So, how much of rebalancing
happens during that open time,
like, do they move or do they stand
still like, roughly [inaudible]
>> That's a great question,
so how much rebalancing occurs?
There is a fair amount
of rebalancing
that occurs in these systems.
Sometimes the drivers do it
while they're online and
sometimes they go
offline and move.
So, we have some
visibility into that
but it's also a
little bit tricky to measure how
much rebalancing
time, interestingly.
Because if they go
out of the app,
turn off the app,
and then come back on in
a different rotation-
>> Is there a real
strategy for them
to kill the app on
when they rebalance?
>> Not necessarily,
interestingly.
Because sometimes they will,
for example, in San Francisco,
they drive all the way
out into the suburbs,
they often want to rebalance
drive back into the city
to get more rides,
but if they leave their app on
while they're driving
up the highway,
they can be dispatched
all along the way,
and the drivers report that they
do better in terms of earnings if
they rebalance all the way
back to the city.
So, which is they do sometimes
go out of the app to move,
to change geographic
location and response to
perceived earnings difference
by geolocation.
>> Quick question about
that sort of stuff.
Do you have evidence of people
that are using both Lyft,
truck drivers that are Lyft
and Uber, and if you do,
is there's a competitive pressure
on for providing
a better experience
that it was the economics
here in terms
of competing for
the attention of the drivers?
>> Yeah. The competitive angle
is obviously an important one,
it's a pretty complicated one.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I think we're
going to leave it
aside for the purposes
of this talk.
But yes, there's definitely,
is not this simple because in
fact one of the model
that I'll introduce,
the simplified model
assumes that the number of
drivers that are on the
system as a response
just to the price
and the earnings,
and that there's no
competitor in that picture,
it's a closed system,
there's only one
geographic region,
so it's simplified
in a lot of ways and
the lack of a competitor
in the model that I'll show
is one of the simplifications.
>> I was just imagining
to decide at this,
you probably have very
strong evidence by launching
these drivers jumped around town
[inaudible] online that their
taxi using these services,
they're actually
[inaudible] to services.
>> It can be hard to tell
if the driver turned
off and got went out of
app in order to move,
rebalance, or took a trip.
On competitor, for example,
there's a limited visibility
into that, yeah.
>> So, like in
my [inaudible] conjecture
that I thought was obvious but
maybe it's false that if
the matching pricing
efficiently design,
then it would never be
individually optimal
for a driver to switch off
the app while he rebalances.
If the matching price
does efficiently,
I would have sold that
he would always be
individually better off
by actually taking three,
rather than giving
up that opportunity.
Is that theorem true?
In practice, the drivers
report that they sometimes-
>> Let might simpler if that
the matching pricing that
you use is not efficient.
So, is the kind of driver that
reported the proof that the
system was inefficient,
or is might conjectural?
>> Yeah. I think it's a
reasonable to assume that
these matching and
pricing algorithms
are not perfectly efficient
in terms of being incentive
compatible and so on.
Okay. So, there's the sense of
sensitivity to pickup time
in addition to
price and to the welfare
maximizing price.
There's actually a market
equilibrium which is
a price and pickup time that
maximizes the welfare for which
there's not much wasted time
in the system.
So, on the left hand side,
I'm showing a situation
where there's not
very many riders and
not very many drivers
unless you can imagine
the pickup times in
this scenario very long,
and so riders and drivers engage
at lower rates with the platform.
Whereas on the right hand side,
with more riders and
drivers in the system,
the pickup times are low,
and the engagement is high.
So, you'll see that
the welfare-maximizing
price and pick
up time combination looks
like this right hand side.
Let's make that concept rigorous.
One key aspect is that there's
a very strong mathematical
relationship between number of
open cars in a particular
geographic region
and the pickup time.
So here what I'm showing
you is we've picked
a particular
geographic region and
we've looked at
different time periods,
and we've gathered data on
the average pickup time
and on the number of
open cars during
those time periods.
Then for each particular
value of the open cars,
like 40 open cars,
all time periods in which
there were 40 open cars,
we looked at what was
the average pickup time,
and that's what's shown
in the blue curve.
You can see that the pickup time
decreases as a function of
the number of open cars,
and in fact, it's
fit remarkably well
with a log linear model
shown in red.
So, this is clear
mathematical relationship
between the two.
Another piece that we'll need is
a steady-state formula for
the number of cars on-trip.
So, if we look at the
trip completion rate capital C
and we multiply by
the amount of time,
the average length of a trip,
the average duration
of the trip that gives
us the steady-state
number of cars on-trip.
So, this is an application
of Little's Law.
So, what we're going to do
in the next slide
is we're going to
break down the number of
total cars by the number
of cars that are on-trip,
the number of cars that are open,
and the number of cars
that are enroute.
So here you go, the three states.
Right now, let's take
a fixed number of total cars.
In fact, in later
slides a note that
the total number of cars
is actually a function of
the price and the pickup
time and so on.
But for right now, just think
about capital N as being fixed,
and then decompose the number
of cars into the number
of open cars capital O,
the number of on-trip
cars which is
the product of
this trip completion rates,
and the trip time capital T,
and then let's apply
Little's Law again on
the right-hand side to
calculate the number of
cars that are in this on
route or pickup state.
So, that's the
trip completion rate
times this at pickup time, ETA,
from two slides
ago that function,
decreasing function as a
function of the number
of open cars. Yes?
>> So, trip completion
rate definition?
>> Okay. So what
we're going to see,
this is a mathematical
formula for how
the trip completion rate must
relate to these numbers.
But we'll see in a moment,
we're going to use this
in order to calculate
the trip completion rate as
a function of the number
of total cars and so on.
Just the number of trips
completed per unit time.
>> Are trips completed per time?
>> Yeah.
Is that clear?
In steady-state the number
of trips completed for open time.
So, it's like the throughput
of the system,
how many trips are we creating
with the system. Yeah?
>> I wonder if
you've thought about
the obvious four stage
of a driver,
which is I am not
logged into the app?
>> Yeah.
>> But hey, I would have
to get a ping if there's
a search happening,
so it'll get open?
>> Yeah.
>> Because people take lunches,
or they at home
watching the game,
or they decide what is
a good time to make some money.
>> Okay?
>> So, I wonder if that will
affect your modeling in anyway.
>> Well, certainly
there's a sense in
which drivers over
the long term will
respond to the amount of money
that they're earning and
that's what we built into
the model a couple
of slides later.
You're talking about
a shorter term aspect,
which is if they're
search pricing right now,
maybe we should give
a push notification.
>> But there's a fourth state.
>> Yeah, there is a fourth
state. So it turns out that
you can capture
that fourth state through
modeling in capital N.
Instead of thinking about
capital N the number of
cars as being fixed,
what we're going to do is
we're going to model it
as a function of the earnings,
and that's implicitly taking into
account the fact that
drivers have another option,
which is not to drive at all.
Good question. Yeah?
>> Congestion level
doesn't affect
the pickup time level
and car relationship?
>> Congestion level, traffic,
and so on, certainly,
it does affect the pickup time
and the trip duration capital
T. We're not going to
focus on that aspect.
The model that we'll
use will be focused on
a particular time of week.
So, we'll condition
on time of week,
and if you say take
downtown San Francisco
in morning rush hour,
traffic conditions are roughly
consistent during
that time period,
and so then we'll just assume
a background traffic level
as we fit these models.
For example, as we are fitting
that curve for pickup time
versus number of open cars,
that should be fit just for
morning rush hour in
that particular geographic
area, for example.
That's a great question. Yes.
>> When you fit
the average pickup time model,
what was the source of
the variance in the
number of open cars?
So, was it because
there's a rush hour.
>> Sure, there's variability
in the number of open cars
simply because, first of all,
if we assume that the
drivers are arriving
according to a Poisson process
and we have a fixed
geographic region,
the number of cars that
arrive is a Poisson
random variable.
So, there will naturally
be some variability,
particularly if we look at a
relatively small
geographic region,
there's some natural variability
in the number of
open cars just due to
that Poisson noise, for example.
Then there's a variety of
additional factors which lead
to additional noise in
the number of open cars.
>> But you'd have to
control for things
like some street was
shut down or stuck
in traffic though.
>> In the model for
pickup time as a
function of open cars,
this model didn't explicitly
take any subtleties
like that into account.
It's just a simple relationship
between the two.
It's a surprisingly good
relationship in this case.
>> To me, it seems
surprisingly wide
variance in the number.
>> The number of open cars.
>> It went from
literally zeros to.
>> Well, there's not
very many time periods in
which we saw those very
high numbers of open cars,
which is why it was a little
noisier down on
the right hand side.
>> So, the number of open cars,
that's an actual number,
like 36 means
36 open cars, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, roughly what percentage
of the entire fleet
does it represent?
How big is that geo?
>> Okay, how big is
the geo that this is based
on? That's a great question.
I think this is roughly a
San Francisco downtown area
but I don't know how
big exactly the geo is.
>> So, roughly, what's
the total number of
cars that are occupied?
>> That are on trip and so on.
In other words, how
does it roughly
breakdown between
the three slides.
>> Right. Percentage roughly,
open cars versus
booked cars [inaudible].
>> It's a great question.
It depends on whether.
>> On your previous slide,
there was actually an answer,
I just realized, it's 40.
Wait, that couldn't be right,
because you said
about half the time,
cars are on trip.
>> Yes, that's correct.
>> Which means that
half the time,
they're either open or
going to the passenger.
>> As a first-order processes?
>> So, let's say half
of them, they're open.
So, that sounds
strange that there are
so few cars in the entire
San Francisco area.
There are only, most of the time.
>> It's not the whole
San Francisco area,
it's some sub region
of downtown but I
don't know how big.
>> Okay.
>> Good. So, let's
take that supply model
from this slide and
let's rearrange to put
trip completion rate,
which is a measure
of value created,
the number of trips created,
let's put that on
the left-hand side.
On the right-hand side,
the number of open cars
and this pickup time,
which is also a function of
the number of open cars.
Let's just treat N and T
as being fixed for
the moment but, again,
we'll come back and
correct that in a minute.
So, if we look at the
trip completion rate, capital C,
as a function of the
number of open cars,
that's the red curve,
and then the blue curve is
just the curve that you
looked at before,
the pickup time,
and you can see that
the trip completion rate
is non-monotonic,
that there's an optimal value,
O star, for the number of
open cars to maximize the
trip completion rate.
Now, if you go above,
for values of the number of
open cars that are above O star,
there's a bit of
the trade off here.
If the number of
open cars is higher,
the trip completion rate
is slightly lower,
but then the pickup time is also
slightly lower so there might be
an experience versus
throughput trade off here.
So, O star is
one way to think about
an optimal system but maybe
there's a bit of
a trade off and there's
a consideration around
slightly higher levels
of open cars.
On the other hand, if
you go to the left,
there's really no advantage
at all, just disadvantage.
So, we look at what
happens to the left,
the number of trips
being completed drops,
and additionally,
the pickup time increases.
So, more wasted time
for riders and
drivers, fewer trips completed.
It's not advantageous to
anyone to be in this zone,
and I'll call this
the danger zone.
You'll see that it
has some implications
for the ability of
the system to serve
riders and drivers.
So, that was a model
that just involved
the cars in
different states. Yes?
>> The danger zone,
whats the implication
in the danger zone
for the earnings per driver?
Since you have fewer
open cars all the time,
it would seem that
the drivers would earn
more in the danger zone.
>> They actually don't earn
Fewer trips are completed.
They spend more time picking up
then they save in
terms of, they, say,
spend less time open but they
spend much more time picking up,
and they're only
paid when they're
in their on trip status.
So actually, this does
not increase earnings.
Great.
So, maybe let's keep
moving a little bit
and then we'll come
back to the questions.
So, let's tie back to prices,
and let's think about
in order to tie into
prices and how surge
prices might work,
let's think about modelling
demand and supply.
For example, we need
to understand how
the trip request volume
on the rider side might
respond to that pickup time
or to the surge multiple.
So, a simple model for that
could be the following,
the number of requests
as a function of
the price and the pickup time.
As the product of the
number of riders who
are opening the app and
checking the price, Lambda,
the function for
the price response, R,
and a function for
the ETA response,
G. This is a simple model
in which we assume
probabilistic
independence between the
two for illustration.
If we look at the data
on the bottom,
the fit actually is
pretty good for these.
So, here's the surge multiple on
the X-axis and on the Y-axis,
the probability of request.
You can see that the blue curve
is the data at each of
these surge multiples and
the red curve is
the fitted model.
So, we have a pretty
good estimate except
some interesting
non-monotonicity is
here around 10 minutes ETA.
So, that's the demand model.
Now, let's put some of
the pieces together.
So, in a steady state model,
the number of riders
requesting rides should be
equal to the number of trips
that are completing
per unit time.
So, that demand model
on the left hand side
should equal the number
of trips completing,
which we derived on
the right hand side.
Additionally, I'm not going to go
into detail on this piece,
but the number of
open cars, capital N,
actually depends on how much
the drivers are earning.
This is what we
talked about before.
So, that's a function
of the price, P,
is also a function of the
number of trips that are
completing per
unit time per driver.
So, solving this system
of equations yields
the pickup time and
the trip completion rate
that's associated
with any given price level,
P. On the next slide,
we'll look at that,
the amount of value,
the welfare created
at each price point,
little p. This is, by the way,
all described in
a paper by Castillo and
colleagues and I'm not
describing Uber's
surge pricing system,
I'm describing how surge pricing
can be done and the
concepts behind it.
So, let's look as a function
of the surge multiplier,
at the amount of welfare
created in system,
that's the red curve.
I've also shown the curve
for the platform revenue and
you can see that
when the search multiple
drops below a certain level,
the welfare drops off a cliff and
much less welfare is created.
The reason for that is that
this is the danger zone,
this is the zone in which
because these pickup
times get long,
a lot of the supply is wasted in
pickup time and it's much
more less efficient.
So, the welfare maximizing prices
basically just above that
cut off for the danger zone.
If the price drops
below that threshold,
the welfare drops precipitously.
These pickup times go up,
the time on trip drops,
the trip completion rate drops.
Okay, so what happens?
The supply and demand conditions
fluctuate over the course
of a day, and so in red,
I'm showing a peak-hours again
in downtown San Francisco,
and in blue, I'm showing
the non-peak hours
in downtown San Francisco.
You can see that the
location of this danger zone
is higher for the peak-hours
than it is for
the non-peak hours,
and the welfare-maximizing
price is
lower during those non-peak hours
than it is during the peak hours.
So, the dynamic pricing systems,
specifically has to keep
the price above this danger zone.
>> If you do it, you think
it's so fragile and
brittle that you want to
be robust to the variation
between your model and reality.
So, do you do active monitoring
to see where you are,
or do you actually try to robust
estimates away from the glyphs?
>> So, I think you're
absolutely correct that there's
a certain amount
of modeling noise
that once you take into account,
this is playing
right on the edge.
Again, this isn't
Uber's surge pricing system,
it's just an illustration
of the concept.
>> Got it.
>> But, yes, in practice,
if you were to implement this,
you would want to take
that into account. Yes?
>> Is it safe to assume
that is what is the opportunity
cost for the driver?
So any multiple less than one,
the driver might be losing
money compared to
doing something else?
>> So, certainly,
the sensitivity of
supply to earnings is part of
what went into this model.
But it's not just the driver.
This is not just
the fact that drivers
have an alternative.
It's due to the fact that
this pickup time phenomenon,
where the pickup times
get really high,
and so the drivers are not
earning money during
those long pickup times.
It has more to do with
that than it does to do
with the drivers' alternatives.
So, one upshot of this is
that if dynamic
pricing is disallowed,
meaning that
the same search multiple
has to be used for
all times and locations,
the welfare maximizing
fixed multiple is
right up here with the dynamic
price for the peak-hours.
The system would end up setting
a higher price if dynamic
pricing is not allowed,
which means that fewer trips are
created and less
welfare is created.
So this is why dynamic pricing is
important in
ride-hailing platforms.
Okay, so I'm going to
talk a little bit about how
to estimate the inputs,
but I also want to
have time to talk
about alternative
matching algorithms.
Were we on time, Eric?
>> I think we're running
a little short today.
>> A little short?
Okay.
>> Can we maybe settle
that later on accounting?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, Esther?
>> Okay.
>> How about 12-15 minutes?
>> Sounds great.
Thank you. All right,
so let's come back to
this demand model,
and remember that lambda here is
the arrival rate for
rider sessions over time,
and part time, and
geographic unit.
So we have to be
able to predict what
lambda is at least in
the very short term.
In the next five minutes,
in the next 10 minutes,
how many riders do we expect to
open the app and
check their price?
I'm going to illustrate this with
New York City taxi data,
which is publicly available.
That's because demand-data and
geolocation for demand is
sensitive for privacy reasons.
But you can see that
in this type of data,
you get these very strong
geographic patterns.
This is Manhattan.
You can see much higher demand
in Manhattan than in
surrounding areas,
and higher demand in
the peak-times than in
the middle of the night.
So, here's a simple illustration
of short-term prediction of
this demands by time
and geolocation.
In this case, the authors used
a random forest model with
discretization of latitude,
and longitude, and time with
a remarkable degree of success
for a simple approach.
So, we're showing here the
prediction on the left,
and the actual on the right,
and you can see they basically
captures the critical features.
There's more density of demand
in these downtown areas.
It's even able to pick up,
the fact that there's more demand
along the thoroughfares in
Manhattan and is able
to capture those daily
cycles effectively.
The input to
the matching algorithms
was this travel time prediction.
Let's just talk about
that for a moment.
So, what does the data look like
for this type of prediction?
The prediction is done using
location data from trips.
So when a driver has
a passenger in the vehicle,
we have GPS data
during that trip,
and that's shown in red
for a particular example,
the sequence of points
starting from top
left to top right.
You can see that in this case,
it looks like the driver
went through a tunnel.
There's one GPS point that has
either very large noise in
the latitude and longitude,
or an incorrect timestamp.
So, certainly,
any algorithms will
need to be robust to that noise.
So, how might one do
travel-time prediction
using this type of data?
The first step is what's
called map-matching,
and John has some wonderful
algorithms for this.
Shown in blue is
the map-matched trip, meaning,
the estimated route and
we also have to
estimate the amount of
time that the driver
took to traverse
each road segment in that route.
And you can see that
this case it did pretty well,
it estimated that the driver
went through the tunnel.
Okay, after this
data-processing step,
then, you can aggregate by
the road segment level.
So here, the histograms here,
these are four histograms for
four particular road segments.
This is actually data
from the project at MSR.
For this particular road
segment, for example,
this is looking at all of
the traversals of
this road segment
during evening rush hour.
>> This is 520. I think
it's 520, isn't it?
>> It's something
like that, yeah.
>> But we all love 520. This
is like the old bridge.
>> These are
the four most commonly
traversed highway road
segments in Seattle,
I don't remember exactly.
And then, the curve
is a model that can
be fit to travel speeds at
the road segment level.
This is some particular
model that we use
for this project
but more generally,
you can think about
creating a model at
the road segment level for
predicting the travel time
across that road segment.
Given a set of predictors,
things like what is
the historical traffic for
this road segment at
this time of week?
What's the historical travel
time for this time of week?
What's the last 15 minutes
average for this road segment
in terms of the travel time?
How's the weather? Is it
a holiday, and so on?
So, there's typically a model
for road segment
traversals times,
and then those individual
predictions are going to be put
together to predict the amount of
travel time between an origin
and a destination in a moment.
Great. So now that we have
these segment level models,
you can then predict in real time
the travel time on
any particular road segment
in the road network.
Here, this is showing
predicted travel speed for
the road segments in
the San Francisco Bay Area,
overlaid on a
satellite photograph.
Green means faster
and red means slower,
and you can see that the highways
have higher predicted speed in
this example than downtown
San Francisco side roads.
This is probably
the middle of the night;
this is an uncongested
time period.
>> Can you share anything
about what you actually prefer
for picking road speeds?
>> For traffic prediction?
>> Yeah. Is the probe network
from Uber itself good
enough to do predictions?
Is not taken multiple sources of
data like we did with
them for Clear Flow?
You don't have to
answer if you can't
answer that question.
>> Sure. Maybe let's
talk offline about it.
>> All right.
>> Thank you.
The primary data source would be
the east traversal times for
vehicles on the road network.
>> But then that's
how you generalize
that signals where
they're not running, so?
>> Yeah, that's a great question.
>> You have a clear flow answer.
>> Okay, so Eric's pointing
out the fact that using
recent data is a great way to
predict traffic if you're
talking about a highway.
It doesn't work so
well in some of
these areas with very
sparse data and,
so a lot of the trick and
traffic modeling is how to
deal with traffic modeling
for the areas with sparse data,
and that's absolutely correct.
So, let's talk about it later.
Great. So then you can put
together these individual
travel times to get travel time
from point A to point B
in the following fashion.
The next step is to compute
the fastest path based on
those traffic predictions.
There's a ton of
different algorithms for this,
like A star, and Hub labeling
algorithms and so on.
Then you could simply
sum the travel
times across that route.
You could stop there,
it turns out that this
doesn't work perfectly,
because you tend to underpredict
the amount of travel time
on the route.
Why is that? Any guesses?
>> Stop lights.
>> Stop lights, but that
should be incorporated,
that's a great call out.
Potentially stop lights we try to
incorporate that into the models,
but yes that's an issue.
>> Dynamically changing.
>> Dynamic, okay so
changes over time.
So the issue is that there's
a consistent
underprediction effect.
If we first find
the fastest route and then
predict the travel time for
that route and that's
because drivers
don't always take
the fastest route.
So there's an
underprediction bias,
and so typically at
this stage there's
some kind of a bias adjustment or
a second model to account
for the fact the drivers are
not always taking
the fastest path.
So it can be simple as
a bias adjustment but
again more sophisticated models
are possible at this stage.
So I do want to come back to
this concept of
novel matching algorithms,
and how might they
help in mitigating
the variability of price
that's introduced
through dynamic pricing.
But here's a simple mechanism.
Let's think about choosing
a waiting window,
call that capital fee,
that's going to be
on the rider side.
This fee could be dynamic,
it could depend on supply and
demand conditions.
So when a rider
requests a ride instead
of only looking at the open cars,
we're going to consider
both the cars that are
open and the cars that
are currently on-trip.
All the on-trip drivers
within few minutes of
completing their trip.
So we're going to expand
the supply base in that sense.
We're going to dispatch the
driver who minimizes either,
the time to pick up if
that's an open driver,
or if it's a driver
that's currently on-trip,
the amount of time
between their drop-off
and the location of
that next rider.
So let's illustrate
that with an example.
So here's a rider, there's
four possible cars,
two of which are currently open
and two of which are
currently on trip.
So this car is five minutes from
the rider so we call
that five minutes.
Eight minutes here,
and on this side,
this is a card that's four
minutes from its drop off.
The drop off location is two
minutes from this rider,
and so we're going
to count that as two
minutes not a six minutes.
Then similarly for
this potential match,
we're going to count
the five minutes
and not the seven total minutes,
and then we're going to
try to minimize that.
So in this case we would
dispatch driver C,
because they minimize
the time between
this drop-off location
and the pickup.
So why this mechanism?
Notice that this is a
dynamic waiting mechanism.
It's asking drivers
to wait a little bit
longer instead of or in
addition to paying
a higher price.
You could even think about
dynamically adjusting
that wait time and dynamically
adjusting the price together.
But the critical thing
to understand about
this mechanism is it's basically
trying to avoid
the danger zone by
optimizing for less wasted time
between trips for drivers.
So it's asking the rider to
flex a little bit in
terms of their time,
but it's minimizing the amount
of time that drivers
spend between on their way
to pick up riders.
This is a similar
concept to some of
the flexing ideas in
one of Uber's products,
the Express Pool product,
where riders are asked to wait
a little bit longer before
they dispatch a driver,
and are also asked to walk
a little bit to
meet their driver.
So what happens? This is
simulation for downtown
San Francisco,
but it's based on actual demand
and supply data from this geo.
In blue what I'm showing is
the optimal dynamic waiting time,
if we allow dynamic waiting
and dynamic pricing.
In red I'm showing the optimal
dynamic waiting time
if we don't allow
dynamic pricing.
You can see that under
the scenario where you have
both dynamic waiting
and dynamic pricing,
you have pretty
reasonable wait times,
anywhere between zero
and four minutes.
So not super high,
these riders are being
asked to wait up to
four minutes longer than
they normally would.
This scenario where
dynamic pricing is not
allowed leads to very
long rider wait times,
probably not going to work
from a product perspective.
So let's go back to that curve
that we looked at before where
we were looking at welfare as
a function of
the price multiplier.
So you saw this
blue curve before,
although I think it
was a different color,
and this is the curve
that showed how
the danger zone effects
shows up as a function
of the surge multiplier.
So this is the curve for welfare
as a function of
the surge multiplier,
and the blue curve
is the case where
there's dynamic pricing but
not dynamic rider waiting,
and the red curve is the case
where both are included.
You can see that
the introduction of
this dynamic rider waiting
moves the danger zone
to the left.
So, reduces the optimal value of
the surge multiplier and also
slightly increases
the total welfare created.
So if you look at
the optimal search multiplier as
a function of the hour of day,
the blue curve is the case
without the rider waiting,
and the red curve is the case
with the rider waiting.
You can see that the surge
multiples are generally lower,
and the variability is less
than the surge multiple from
one time period to the next.
Any questions? Yeah.
>> I have a general
question about
the predictability
of this system.
So let's say you have
two consecutive days with
exactly the same
conditions in terms
of demand and all that.
Would the prices
behave similarly,
or the dynamics would
behave similarly?
Maybe think of the notion
of equilibrium in
other multiple equilibria or
a single equilibrium in
these kind of scenarios.
>> So, single equilibrium
given fixed supply and
demand conditions,
but the supply and
demand conditions do
fluctuate a fair amount
even day to day.
If you look at the the
short-term prediction of demand,
in fact you get
these local fluctuations
in supply and demand.
>> Exactly the same demand and
supply across two different days.
>>Then you'll get
the same surge price,
because the surge price is
a function of
the supply and demand.
What am I not understanding?
Oh you're saying
because the drivers respond-
>> Yes. I'm thinking about
the notion in Nash setting
like unique equilibrium,
is there unique equilibrium
in this kind of setting?
>> Yes. So, for
a given price point there
is an equilibrium value
for the waiting time,
under fixed supply and
demand conditions.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
There's a theorem about that,
I didn't include it in the talk.
Great.
So, to conclude this growth
of ride-hailing is facilitated
by these matching and
pricing algorithms.
These algorithms
reduce the wasted time
for both riders and for drivers.
They require forecasts of demand,
of supply, and travel time.
We talked about how one might
generate those forecasts.
We also talked about
how introducing
different matching algorithms
might be able to help
decrease the price variability
associated with dynamic pricing.
Then, there's this meta point
around the fact that this
isn't just machine learning
that we're doing.
It's a mix of economic models,
statistical approaches,
machine learning,
and optimization.
Thanks very much.
>> We're up for a few
questions. Yeah, go ahead.
>> So, regarding
the new matching you showed,
so where you look at
the drop-off time and you
measure only the distance.
So is it the entire algorithm
or there is a cutoff?
Because maybe there
is a drop off.
>> The cutoff is capital is Phi,
so that's what we're flexing.
Is the maximum amount of
extra waiting that we would
require from the rider.
>> The second question I
had was more open-ended.
I'm thinking like in
terms of the drivers,
is there in our data,
what is the amount of
money made by each driver?
Is it fair across
all the drivers or?
>> Okay. So, fairness of
earnings across drivers.
>> Yeah, because
these policies can determine
which driver will be
dispatched to the customer.
So, and it explicitly
does not take into
account the "fairness" of
the drivers or something.
>> So, it depends on what
you mean by fairness.
>> In terms of the-
>> These are fair mechanisms in
the sense that nothing is
specific to that driver, right?
But, the mechanisms discussed
here are all mechanisms that
have only to do with the distance
between a rider and
a driver, for example.
They're not personalized
in any sense.
So, they're fair in that sense.
Fairness is perhaps
a longer discussion
if you wanted to say, "Okay,
if you're trying to
create earnings that
are as similar across
drivers as possible,
and to reduce variability
across drivers as
much as possible."
That's an interesting question
and a longer one to address.
>> Like the data which says
like roughly speaking,
they make the average amount
of money made for
the driver is roughly
the same, or something.
>> There's some data for that
publicly available in papers.
I don't have that on
the tip of my tongue.
>> Do you have
a question over here?
>> Yeah. I had a question
about how do you
assess the demand?
Say if I'm just opening my app
into new prices, right?
I'm not requesting it,
does that go into the model of,
does it categorize as demand?
>> Yes, so that's
exactly what Lambda
was in this model for.
So, predicting demand, so we
basically assume the number
of riders opening the app
and checking the price
is just a function of
time and geolocation,
it's not a function of
what price I search multiple,
we happen to have right now and
then we assume that the chance of
the rider requests after
they're showing the price does
depend on what price you showed
them, that's how
we break it down.
So, then this prediction,
you have this prediction
of number of riders
opening the app and
checking the price, yes.
>> Just like, write a script
which keeps pinging the service,
does that mean the prices for
everyone else around
me will come?
>> So, we're aware that
people could do this and
so we have safeguards in
place to avoid them,
specifically this.
>> So, it seems
natural that once you
start having riders being
willing to wait a little while,
that the price multiple could
come down a little bit.
I was wondering if
you guys looked
at other matching mechanisms?
I'm curious about, for instance,
if someone says that they're
willing to wait longer,
you could just have them
sit around for awhile,
and then see what
other customers have popped
up at the same time,
what cars are available,
then and then do
the matching in
a delayed fashion.
>> Great. So, the question was
around asking riders
to wait a little bit
longer to be matched
and whether giving
riders the option to wait
a little bit longer might,
instead of asking them to pay
more could be advantageous,
is that correct?
>> The last section
you just talked about
the mitigating price variability.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you have this mechanism
where people can wait
a little longer,
and the way you do the matching
is based on what cars
are going to be close to them at
that point in the future, right?
But, I can propose
an alternative mechanism
where a customer says,
"I'm willing to wait
a couple of minutes extra."
So, you wait the couple minutes,
and then see what
other customers are
shown up around them,
and what are the cars around
and then do the matching.
That's seems like this would
be another simple alternative.
I was just curious if
the one that you showed
is the best among many
that you've explored,
or it's just really early in
the exploration of
these things, or?
>> It turns out it's the one
that's easier to analyze which
is why I used it in the
simplified mathematical model.
But, you're absolutely
correct that
this batching mechanism
could be valuable.
I think Lyft talks about doing
it in one of their blogs,
but I'm not 100 percent
certain about that.
Certainly in Express Pool,
it's something that rider see,
they request a ride, and
then there's some time
before they're actually
matched to a driver.
So, yes absolutely, this is
used by these
ride-hailing services.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> How creative is
the team that's coming
up with- raised
some new mechanisms?
For example, I've been on Uber,
where I feel to pay a lot
more for a faster ride,
it's like, give me an option
to pay for a faster.
That would propagate
through a whole system
to new models where
people willing to
pay higher prices even an auction
model for getting a faster ride.
Is it easy to suggest and test,
to experiment with
new ideas like this?
Or it's just really quite
conservative in terms of
how you roll things out?
>> There have been a variety
of products that have
been introduced that
specifically leverage
this difference between
drivers and their tradeoff
between waiting time and price.
I would argue that
the fact that there's
Express Pool and
POOL and UberX is
exactly providing
that flexibility to riders.
In terms of introducing
a new product,
there is a user interface change.
We do have to be a little bit
careful about showing
a fourth option when
there's already a lot of
options. But, in terms of-
>> It's really fast, pay
more prices won't you
>> Adjusting some of
the back-end mechanisms is a
little bit more easier
to explore with.
>> All right. Thanks.
>> Thanks so much.